The Joe Rogan Experience this guy is a
gigantic fan of yours I mean like Beyond
so he's if he like seems like a little
awestruck right now that's what's going
on yeah he's very polite thank you I was
raised on raised on pro wrestling and uh
I didn't know what a Rolex or a jet or
anything was until you came out when I
was eight years old and I'm like what
the hell is this guy beating the good
guys when it literally just Preposterous
that's what this guy was well it's you
took the art of the promo like the
interview to a completely different
level you really did you made it so fun
yeah thank you I was having fun making
them how did you develop that sort of
style like was that something you always
had is this something you cultivated for
pro wrestling like no I love pro
wrestling as a kid I watched it all the
time and then my dad would take me to a
match on uh my birthday or something
like that right and then um
I was going to play football University
of Minnesota and academically and
eligible after a semester
stayed in a fraternity house for two
years told my parents I was still in
school
foreign
came to town and I got a chance to break
him with Vern and
I just kind of grew up on Joe Namath you
know going back to where I got that when
I saw Joe Namath
in Miami in the main coat with the
chicken and the lawn chair I said that's
me and then
he had uh that he had slept with 300
women at Alabama I said that's my that's
my game I got to figure out how to get
there there's a video I'm sure you've
seen it of these football players you
know what the team was whether they're
called Sergio Brown yes and they're all
so see Jamie see if you can find it
because it's one of my absolute favorite
Clips on the internet
and these guys are reciting your lines
word for word yeah Sergio Brown God
bless
[Applause]
you know I've done this at a show before
where you could just say Ric Flair and
you point the microphone out and the
whole crowd goes thank God it's amazing
I mean that's an amazing thing you're
like literally the only human being
that's connected to a sound yeah you go
RIT Flair and they go whoa how did that
was that something that just came out
one day one promo I'm telling you we
used to drive you know three my three
thousand 3500 miles a week sometimes
four I mean at night you're just
listening to
music and drinking beer and throwing
cans at the signs you know in the old
days and driving 100 miles an hour and I
heard Jerry Lewis called goodness
gracious It's a Great Balls of firewood
oh wow but the emphasis wasn't on the
woo as much as you know the thing and I
went [__] that's the next day on TV I
said
that's how it all started wow 1974.
Sherry Lee Lewis the record is the race
is a good Balls of Fire oh my God that's
amazing I have a question uh you once
cut a promo when you went when you were
back in WCW and NWO and all that was
happening and you start taking off your
Rolex and your clothes and you're
threatening Eric Bischoff and at one
point you take out your turn he's
tearing up hundred dollar bills he's
trying to get the owner of the WCW out
you're gonna come out of your handcuffs
himself to the thing another I mean it
is so funny it's epic he for some reason
you do an elbow drop on nothing at one
point
my goodness sir starting to
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
laughs
it gets better and better deep at one
point
my house
my car
whatever my
I'll sign it over to you I will give you
the satisfaction of saying you're right
the Nature Boy if you have the you know
what to walk the aisle here tonight one
more time
[Music]
he drops an elbow for no reason
[Applause]
[Music]
the one stimulation
I think it's back actually right here
it's right here
[Applause]
I ain't going home
for you get your ass out here come on
okay
[Applause]
you turn the camera off and I'll be
naked when you come back
[Laughter]
he incubs himself to the [__] room
and at one point you're ripping up
hundred dollar bills and you take off
Gucci shoes and you throw them into the
crowd did you ever get those back no
I always wondered after I grew up older
and learned about like production and
stuff I'm like oh there must have been
an assistant over there that he threw it
out because there's no way just throw it
launches it into the
of Jesus Christ a two thousand dollar
shoe
oh here he goes this is it watch this
he's just he's about to drop an elbow
there's nobody there
[Laughter]
[Applause]
there's something wrong with me when
you're out there doing this do you have
any plan no nothing no just free balling
the whole thing yeah did you know you're
gonna take your clothes off I had I had
a plan but I wasn't sure I didn't I
didn't run it by anybody because I know
he'd never go for it
where how do you do what was your method
of Madness to that like that part The
Cutting promo part of Ric Flair you'd
have a loose plan and you just let it
rip or did you have any practice or
anything like what would you no I just I
just thought about it um
we had been in that legitimate lawsuit
legitimately don't like each other to
this day
I mean we've we've agreed to agree but
um
I was pushed down so far in the company
that like the NWO was a featured act
which I didn't have a problem with but
don't abuse me right so I was taking my
son to the Au Nationals in Detroit I'd
ask the lawyer for the time off not
missing Nitro listening Thunder the
secondary show nobody went to right
right and he sued me and he walked in
front of a
about 85 people and said it was going to
break me he said he's an Executive Vice
President of Turner gonna break me
ruined my family destroy me and all that
and so I could assumed I would have been
a multi-millionaire but then I wouldn't
have been able to wrestle again right so
after I waited I sat home for a year
cost me a million dollars and
I said [__] it I'll go back and then
because they wouldn't they wouldn't give
me a release
and they gave me my check each week but
the minute I cashed the check that I
would be
admitting that I work for him again so
just another screw job then he ended up
bankrupting the company anyway so right
or not he the the combination of things
right exactly he's going up against
Vince McMahon well they thought they
were going to put Vince out of business
that's where they made their biggest
mistake right
Vince is a very smart guy
hence the Attitude Era yeah
they had 83 weeks that's it